I'll be traveling for 10 days soon and what are you about flying with the right
machine? Is it typical okay to travel with? Yes, you should have no trouble
traveling with it. You can carry it. It's carrying case. If you do that I would
bring it as a carry on. Not I would not check it. But I put my right machine
and wrapped it in a sweatshirt, put it in my baggage and checked my luggage, fell
problem and I brought it in on my carry on. No trouble. I've never brought to
big plastic case. I've always to conserve space, wrapped it in a sweatshirt or
something like that and put it in my travel bag. What I brought it and carry it as
a carry on. Most the time they will pull you aside and they will look at it. When
they x-ray it, it doesn't look like a bomb but they may think what's this. And
sometimes they just look at it and just swap it down and let you go and
sometimes they've asked me what's this and I say it's a right machine and then
they look at me and they shake their head and they swap it down and give it back to me.